[Music]
so
much
we know this part
it's just like yesterday's technique
okay
the initial energy is going into his
shoulder right into his shoulder
into his shoulder
whoa
shoulder
injury
and then i let it turn
we don't have to talk about that part
that was yesterday
all right
look you have to yield
and you have to establish a ground path
you don't stand here
double-weighted
even weight distribution
boom yield hop
turn
so
what
do i mean no
double weighted
no yield
then
whoa
no balance when you're double weighted
and then it gets worse when you pivot
double weighted
you don't do that you don't pivot double
weighted you never
ever
pivot
double weighting
never here
like that now
that's why you see all those people
single pivot point
turns on the single pivot point
to the other two quite nicely
warm
up
different
let's get this single pizza box
on that turn before going on
okay now that you have a single pivot
point you can turn quite a bit
go way past the
180.
so once you've given yourself that
capacity you're going to turn
into him
this is not enough this technique is not
lined up
turn into him
here is the edibi angle if you pay
attention so here i was and i'm going to
do er eating me nugget
can you see
that means he's in the back
outward kazushi if i go over here
and i try to do it you can oh no that's
not it okay
so you're gonna turn
woe
all the way into him
looking at him
cut it not here
so same single pivot
all the way into him
looking right at him you were in the
back do you see go in the back
okay
go all the way around go
oh if i do tenshi nugget yeah
outward kazushi do you see
that means his energy is going which way
forward
his energy is going forward
well i'm not going to change that
i'm not going to go here
and he's going backwards
so
what why as i keep turning
i'm keeping him
so that his center keeps going up
okay now we gotta figure out how
well
keep your turn pay attention to this
hand
this hand is gonna go back into him this
way
you see
don't bring his hand this way and go
pull him backwards
oh
back into him
okay center goes up
back into him going this way
oh this way
we're going this way
just ever so slightly
oh this way
and that's where i interned
arm going this way
let it go in this way
this is different
and this is different too
you just see him to get in the x pattern
there it is right here
that's where you do the eating okay
and again you're throwing his body
in the body lock
body
here
now it's in the lock
in the wall and then you need me oh
accelerate your backwards
got it
pulling him down
okay you have to be stronger than him
and more athletically again
okay you're not quite getting this body
lock because it's not as obvious as
locking it between my hip and
it's not as obvious okay
but that
that body lock doesn't happen
because it's locked here and i'm
tripping him
it happens because oh over here i
already i can have it with one hand
through the ikea adhesion
so i have to do the ice adhesion here
too okay
so i'm coming around
whoa
turn it is going that way
but what do you think happens to a
circle benjamin goes this way and so i'm
not pulling him down
[Music]
i'm going to do the same body lock and
the way that he twists here
he's going to twist here too same exact
thing enter
turn his body okay
boom
okay
wrong
don't pull down here
yeah he smells close it doesn't matter
work the technique
hold turn
turn
[Music]
try to get your foot on me
all right so
uh in this in this variant what i have
decided to do
is a
pin i i decided to do that okay
uh
as i'm gonna work on this pin i'm gonna
work on this strike okay
uh if i wanted to work
on
oh stomp i would work on the stump
if i wanted to work on a ditch
and get distance and get my firearm in
the game i'd work on that
so
i'm working on a pin
okay
pins require that he's thrown under me
not away from me
okay
so
hand come here
and try to accelerate him backwards
it does not land under me
and you're going to have to move up
which means you didn't have control for
a few moments
this
he's going to go
right where i want to go
right where this hand is
japanese
pop
okay into the throw
boom
right there
do you see
i throwing him under this hand
oh
he's gonna
land right underneath that hand
underneath that where's my weight on my
spine line
okay
not off
off
not out
under
so you have to think ahead
boom
you're already thinking where's that hat
right here
where i put all my weight on
then you can pin
and you can strike he's under you okay
let's try it
so again i'm not throwing him down
i made me a fallen body
the reason i stay up with him is because
i stayed up with him i'm not pushing him
down
okay
somewhere long before you get to what
you recognize as the fall he was already
falling if i'm doing it right
if i'm doing the other
accelerations
he's not falling yet you see you have to
pull and pull and pull
but if you get for example the body lock
he's already calling
he said
i just stayed up with him
and then aimed him
intentionally
he was already followed okay that way i
can enter because he's going into a yin
phase
all right same exactly here
whoa
you just had to do the same body
okay
let's see what we get because i have a
feeling some of you are still pulling
him down
and that's why he's going away from you
because you're accelerating him which
means you
are increasing his velocity in a
direction away from you that's why he's
not underneath you okay